c'est non non non mon cher pierre
faisant étant de réfléchir après parce
que je vais me tourner je vais pivoter
vers vous en quelque sorte oui car vous
êtes devenu un écrivain oui c'est un
grand mot il ya une somme quand même
vous allez sortir en septembre une somme
puis l'a montré d'ailleurs qu'elle sera
présente quelques pages sont ce qu'on
appelle les bonnes feuilles oui mais
combien de temps kingson ses 19 ans un
peu un peu considérable quand même oui
et c'est considérable se rappelle
comment c'est le manuel de savoir vivre
à l'usagé des rustres et des malpolis ah
bon ça soit de quoi pas ça traite des
bonnes manières parce que plus ça va
plus les gens sont généralement grossier
sur surtout les
les gens qui sont un peu con et fumiers
et son grossier généralement accents
grossi alors j'écris un livre pour leur
apprendre les bonnes manières bien alors
on peut on peut avoir quelques petits
exemples ne dit rien oui mais en
plusieurs chapitres on peut lire par
exemple vous parlez comment comment
reconnaître un homme d'une femme on la
retient comme encore important série
vendéen d un père oui
alors pour connaître un homme d'une
femme par exemple si on déshabille un
homme une femme la première chose qui
saute aux yeux c'est que l'homme à
dessein grotesque et ridicule
ridiculement embryonnaires même d'un
rapport à la vénus de milo par exemple
c'est une indication c'est pas une
preuve pour être sûr de ne pas nous
leurrer approche en ou encore un peu
pinson légèrement le sein de la personne
si la personne dit oh oui albert soit
mien c'est une femme
en revanche si la personne dit pourquoi
vous me regarde enfin parce que je parle
de ce 1 voilà au revoir je suis la
personne dit alors albert mon pote ça
pas la tête c'est un homme
oui deuxième exemple ça ça commence bien
il faut dire oui deuxième exemple la
drague alors y ait beaucoup de vulgarité
dans la drague oui il ya des techniques
de drague qui sont plus ou moins
élégante et la technique d'abordage dit
de jean gabin oui pourquoi de jean gabin
pas pour la simple raison qu'ils entrent
qu'il en fut l'inventeur s'est nettement
la technique d'abordage le plus efficace
jean gabin qui fut un chaud lapin avant
de devenir un lapin froid et loris
c'est un grand malheur jean gabin
pousser la difficulté dans la drague
jusqu'à n'aborder que des filles
accompagnées de leurs parents ça c'est
très élégant alors il entrait dans un
salon de thé de sa démarche de
moissonneuses batteuses bien connu et se
plantait les mains dans les poches
devant une table ou papa maman fifi
siroter leur thé citron il allumait une
gauloise en dominant des chefs comme il
sait faire il regardait la mer puis le
père puis disait à la fille t'as d'beaux
yeux tu sais chat bosvieux si ça
marchait
encore un point important on les bonnes
manières c'est comment reconnaître
l'amour de l'amitié à west ham en charge
des sentiments qui se frôlent mais qui
sont pas totalement identique alors si
on la sent face à face deux personnes
nus de sexe opposé dans une chambre
tendu de velours rouge avec des des
glaces au plafond de la moquette angora
parterre du champagne des assauts
d'argent et du blues en sourdine bon si
au bout d'un quart d'heure une des deux
personnes s'exclame c'est con sic on
sera trois on pourrait faire une belote
on ne peut pas parler d'amour
c'est l'amitié en revanche les sont côte
à côte deux éboueurs à l'arrière d'une
benne à ordures à 6h du matin si au bout
d'un quart d'heure l'un des deux
éboueurs regarde l'autre éboueurs avec
intensité en disant ça m'excite de vider
les poubelles auprès de vous on ne peut
pas parler d'amitié c'est l'amour
d'autres exemples comme ça permet aussi
beau je crois pas
j'ai fait un chapitre qui traite les
bonnes manières la guerre c'est assez
intéressant ces grossières de ces
ventres et
on voulait quelque chose non plus petit
scooter d'abord patins inférieurs croisé
supérieur l'inférieur doit saluer le
supérieur c'est charmant de coutume
s'appelle le salut pour saluer
l'inférieur porte sa main droite là en
mettant les mains comme ça suivez bien
quant à supérieur entre dans la chambre
d'un inférieure ce dernier doit ça lui
en bombant le torse s'il n'a plus de
torse comme cela arrive à la guerre il
doit bombes et les genoux ou n'importe
quoi de bombes à bhl c'est la pollution
dite du garde à vous
dans le garde-à-vous on doit mettre le
petit doigt sur la couture du pantalon
et les pieds comme ça
attention avant de saluer un supérieur
il faut être sûr que c'est un supérieur
un supérieur est un est un gradé un
gradé se reconnaît au nombre de ces
buret plus le gradé à bure est plus le
salut doit être servile
c'est joli non c'est pas mal
je peux vous dire voir ailleurs parce
que la marche vers la paix il voulait
revoir c'est normal mais j'ai appris
quelque chose de la presse récemment
pierre je sais que vous n'êtes pas citer
longuement s'est arrêté pour le moment à
la grosse la grand délire une émission
harry grand succès et qui était bien
heures rick était bien vous en avez
enregistré un épisode pour la télévision
eh bien j'ai appris que cet épisode
n'était pas passé attendez laissez moi
finir oui parce que vous aviez prononcer
plusieurs fois pardonnez-moi tâche
certains spectateurs le moc et kate est
ce que c'est vrai oui pour ça que
c'était mission kate a été prononcée
effectivement je crains que ce soit par
mois parce que je pense que paul
préboist qu'ils faisaient l'un des
témoins dans l'émission à parler d'eux
il a dit le sexe c'est un mot très
vulgaire je dis que vous pouvez dire
quéquette nous sommes entre nous et
c'était très mal reçue je pense par la
chaîne
par antenne 2 c'est pourtant qui est
musulman oui mais non mais quel point le
moc etc est très mignon enquête est un
mot qui est très bien travaillé antenne
2 oui en plus non mais ce qui
se passe
mais en fait non ce qui se passe c'est
glauque et kate est très bien compris
des enfants jusqu'à 4 ans 4 ans et demi
et après on oublie et un directeur de
chaîne ne sais plus ce que c'est quand
on parle je crois que c'est ça les agace
au
[Musique]
fait que non non